killings in New York City subway systems
Skyrocket to highest level in 25 years
even as ridership plummeted this is part
of an ongoing Trend we've seen across
the country crime is skyrocketing
homicides are aggravated assaults and
robberies these horrifying stories a
woman gets pushed on the subway tracks a
naked dude running through the subway
and if you saw that people uh in
Philadelphia a woman with raped I was
gonna say and people just watched it
happen filmed it they didn't just watch
it they pulled out their phone right and
that's right around I'm telling you my
kids and I we every every weekend during
the summer we were on the train from
Philadelphia going into New York and we
would spend the weekend in New York
every single weekend during the summer I
have not been to New York in two years
now because it is crazy I mean just case
in point in Philadelphia before the
George Soros backed uh district attorney
Larry krasner came into office there are
six County jails and Phil Philadelphia
and they were at or Max Capacity at
capacity is a little over 8 000 right
Larry krasner George Soros back district
attorney Larry krasner comes into office
and instead of it being at 8 000 he put
it down to I'm around up 5 000 right so
8 000 minus five thousand there's three
thousand more people who would generally
be in jail somewhere just in
Philadelphia I'm not talking about all
of Pennsylvania just in the Philadelphia
County three thousand people who would
generally be locked up somewhere and not
up and not out there on the streets able
to impact the law-abiding citizens
they're now out there and when you ask
Larry krasner why are you doing this
Larry he says things like oh I want to
do family reunification right the broken
home and the black family we need to get
people out of jail and put them back
home with the people right but that's
three thousand what part
I'm sure there are some portion of that
3000 who uh who should not be in this
situation is you know wrong they
shouldn't be there but how many of the
three thousand the whole 3 000 or a
smaller portion of that three thousand
that is the reason why we have crime at
the rate that it is our our judicial or
judicial system has been turned into a
revolving door they should put video
webcams in prisons for people because if
they should be able to unify with their
family and communicate with their family
everybody should even imprison in my
opinion if you want people to become
better people as a result of being there
and let them do that but if they're
violent criminals I don't put them back
outside the fear of losing the country
is that there's so much violent crime
that the government can't stop it and
then we appeal to private corporations
to bring in private security and that's
the loss then then we've lost our
country then the corporations run the
show so that's what I want to avoid this
is all manufactured chaos
manufactured uh uh loss I mean it's just
manufacturing the reason because they
want us to be dependent well it's almost
like there's this very
um massive
you know like a restart happening you
know like a big a big step yes something
like that great something different
great reset yeah maybe that one's fine
so what they say is uh what the
activists were telling me back during
occupies From the Ashes of the old we
shall build a new that in order to build
the system they want they got to knock
down the old one this is this is the
idea so you have crime crushing these
cities people are fleeing them and then
you can come in what did Bill de Blasio
say when the when the property value is
tanked he's like now we can buy them up
and create government housing on the
cheap and so so you have a government
that implements policies that destroys a
private real estate industry then the
government comes in and buys it for
pennies on the dollars to on the dollar
to create their government policy with
with new land they've acquired from the
policies that destroyed them
yep a lot like it except they did it
with guns they didn't even bother
bankruptcy and they're already so rich
and I used to always say to myself you
know running for office again I mean you
know I was at I mean I've had many
careers I'm an author you see my book
back there nothing to lose everything to
gain being black and conservative in
America
um a news commentator work uh military
uh was accepted into officer candidacy
School worked in the financial industry
worked as a adjunct professor of
corporate finance I've had a lot of
different careers in my lifetime um but
right before I decided to get into
politics I was a stay-at-home mom and I
was homeschooling my children we've
always lived in really great school
districts I just believed I could do it
better than what my babies would have
been learning in the school system
especially when they come home and my
daughter is being taught about same-sex
marriage and my son is being taught
about a different family configurations
in third grade I was like I think we can
do this better honey and so we started
homeschooling our kids and so this was
never on my bucket list of things to do
but we need to engage our government and
we need to do it now we need to debate
demand better not from Democrats but
from Republicans because a lot of this
stuff that's going on I don't know if
you guys even know about podesto
Bill Clinton's uh former Chief of Staff
Hillary Clinton yeah exactly right yeah
he is now Biden has now tapped him to to
to
um being his administration to
specifically work in the climate change
yes the almost 400 billion dollars is
now under his hands and what do you
think he's going to do with that this is
a a very a highly political figure he's
going to send this money into different
campaigns and different organizations
that will now I suspect who will now
turn around and donate that money to
these particular campaigns now if I know
that and you know that I'm sure Ted Cruz
and others know that and why are these
people Republicans who see themselves as
president one day not standing up and
shouting us from the rooftop
shells or they just don't realize that
we can recover the carbon and reuse it
out of the atmosphere with the carbon
dioxide just pull the carbon dioxide
because they they want to do electric
grids like people Thomas Massey was
talking to Pete booty judge about
electric cars requiring like twice as
much electricity as a refrigerator
American's refrigerator and how by 2030
if everyone has one electric car how can
the grid handle that and booty judge is
like his response is well it's gonna
have to and Tom's like no no no how will
we do it yeah they don't have an answer
you that's the old Sheamus joke that
when you say okay you want you want good
thing how do you get it they go you want
bad thing well then you want bad thing
if if you question them at any point as
to how they actually will Implement
their utopian Vision they just say
you're a fascist it has to get done
Putin sympathizer right listen these
people have a lot of knowledge but they
lack wisdom right I don't think they
have a lot of knowledge or wisdom well
no they lack wisdom they see a hammer
and a male and instead of using it for
its intended purposes they look at a
hammer and nail and say look I found a
doorstop and a key right it just this
isn't how the world worked it's not how
any of this works and yet these people
are now running our country and that is
a fact and all of this is happening if
you want to assume ignorance but it also
could be intentional the reason we have
crime skyrocketing in these cities is
because they want it to happen because
they want the economy to be destroyed
it's because they want to have a great
reset exactly it's either that or they
are some of the most incompetent people
ever and when I listen to Janet Yellen
Janet Yellen is no dummy this is a very
smart woman and when she talks about
transitory inflation I repost it today
an article I wrote in November of 2021
and I was like news flash this ain't
transitional this is going to stay this
is going to be very sticky I spent three
months with our Farmers I was like let
me just start off with the very
beginning of our supply chain and let me
let you hear what farmers are saying
about Fuel and the cost of fuel oil
right now is up 137 percent and I'm like
this is not transitory this is going to
be very sticky this is going to destroy
lives and yet Janet Yellen Jerome Powell
they're all out here talking about
transitory inflation now I have to say
either these these are some of the the
dumbest people who have ever managed to
get their hand on power or they know
exactly what they're doing right I think
they know exactly and these are not dumb
people not all of them maybe Janet
Yellen knows right
knows they are they you know look when
we were talking about this the other
night when Victoria Newland said that
there are biological research facilities
in Ukraine that we're very concerned
about Russia getting their hands on we
want to protect them
and then the media comes out immediately
saying bio Labs don't exist bio Labs
don't exist okay well they know they do
they know they're concerned about them
and then we had a conversation with the
guest where he said there's no
biological weapons research Labs the US
isn't doing that and I'm like it's a
semantic argument
right so it's it's you have these people
in the media in government saying the
U.S does not do these things and then
they go and do them but then argue
semantics about it so my example was if
a guy created a factory that was
building explosives and someone said
this dude's building a weapons Factory
no the explosives are for Mining and
it's like okay those can be sold off and
used as Weapons right yes okay so we're
having a semantic argument you're making
something dangerous of course and like
transitory inflation is semantic like
it's transitory for now until yeah
it's just another form of transition
it's the meme where they're like first
inflation isn't happening then inflation
uh might be happening but it's not that
big of a deal next inflation is
happening but it's transitory finally
inflation's a good thing here's how it
helps that's what they do coming out I
mean I watched eight hours of the big
banks in America testifying before the
house committee uh the Banking Committee
in the house and it was astounding to me
when they asked a question do you
believe Jerome Powell can can handle and
stop this inflation they all raised
their hand yes yes we agree and then
Jamie dimon Camp comes out right after
that saying the Federal Reserve is my
judge is my judge jury and hangman so of
course if it's something that you that
you alluded to earlier they are
controlled the banks are controlled by
the Federal Reserve they're going to
dance to whatever tune uh Jerome Powell
plays because again as as Jamie Diamond
said they are judge jury and hangman so
they're going to do whatever they need
to they're going to say whatever they
need to say and the Federal Reserve is
owned do you know who owns it not not
the people yeah it's a private company
that's basically adherent to the bank
for international settlements in
Switzerland the bank of England the
Federal Reserve of New York and the bank
of Australia like run through this node
the Swiss bank node called the bank for
international settlements I don't know I
think it's the same people that own
BlackRock and State Street that own and
run that thing but it's also behind the
scenes and it there's hasn't yet been
like an audit or oversight it's
intentionally created so that we don't
have oversight over the company well
well the Senate is supposed to have
oversight over uh um oversight over the
Federal Reserve to clarify their
mandates would be one thing of
stabilizing prices uh but the it yeah so
I mean so so they're supposed to have
oversight over them how do you see the
transition of our economy right now what
do you see happening I see like like the
new world order they want to move to
this liberal you know Global one world
at least I do but what do you how do you
see the America
progressing yeah economically I think
we're in and and for some really hard
days
um I you know when when you hear the
Federal Reserve chair saying I am
committed to destroying demand now
they're talking about demand destruction
that's how they they coin it and when I
was listening to it I heard several
people say on you know on the The
Talking Heads demand destruction demand
destruction I'm like I still have family
who live on that pig farm in Southern
Alabama the farm is no longer operable
but they're very poor and when I hear
demand destruction I immediately see
faces I immediately see who you know who
is going to be destroyed in this process
these people are uberly wealthy this is
not going to impact them very much the
Federal Reserve is the number one reason
why we have income inequality right now
and now they are also creating a lack of
Opera an opportunity Gap right between
those who have and have not that Gap is
is growing growing going growing in the
first year of covet of 2020 our nation
increased the number of millionaires by
30 percent and I'm and I'm talking to
people who are getting pay cuts like 35
pay cuts right and I'm listening to the
media talking about we're all in this
together and yet our nation at one of
the most you know destructive times in
our economy and lives we were growing
the number of millionaires by 30 percent
if you went into covet with a
significant amount of assets the best
thing that ever happened to you as the
Federal Reserve specifically began to
shift wealth uh from the people to
certain entities right they are the
number one reason for this wealth Gap
that we have and now we're looking to
the Federal Reserve to fix what the
Federal Reserve broke in the first place
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there